this planet watching gold
trends in a you to resist early
so we found again some more information
about the Christmas special including
some posters
was a nice Easter Egg see even pick up
Ali in the background but
so many do you have questions about
which version of the doctor Peter
the party's going to be 18 Steven Moffat
has said some things about the doctor
being the 14th incarnation so that it
%uh video the top five reasons why the
doctor can survive past is 12
regeneration limit
that be considered with Steven Moffat is
actually said is that what we're going
to do is call Peter Capaldi
the twelfth doctor but in reality he is
like the 14 doctor because Steven Moffat
is counting like them a crisis
and others partial regeneration if you
didn't see it I also started at your
initial call ask emergency
it is a show where I can take your guys
questions and answer them directly in a
video
so my next will be a doctor who addition
be sure to subscribe to get it and leave
your questions after this video about
their generations or anything doctor who
related
let's get started these are my top five
reasons why the doctor can survive past
as well for generations limit
number five the time later able to grant
new regeneration cycles
during the five doctors they actually
offered the master in the regeneration
cycle
even though they never delivered they
were able to offer that because the
event to the day the doctor
now that we know Gallifrey has survived
if the doctor ever does find it
it's possible for them to grant him a
new regeneration cycle in exchange for
saving outbreak number four
River song's early Christmas present so
during let's kill Hitler she granted the
doctor
all for remaining generations we saw her
regenerate once the child
and then twice during let's kill Hitler
that leaves a tree generations remaining
if you don't count the actual
regeneration that he'll the doctor
but then you to subtract one more after
the time the doctor he'll River song's
broken wrist during the Angels Take
Manhattan
that would leave seven-up rivers for
generations the doctor has left
it's unclear as to whether for
generations work like a faucet but you
can turn it on a little bit and just use
a little bit every generation energy
orbit like a light switch like you flick
it once and that counts as 1
regeneration
number three advanced regeneration
theory so over classic you and modern
who their bit different theories about
how time larger generate and what
regeneration is
this could actually be an entire course
on community so so make of it
Steve mother could use one of these
alternate regeneration theories as a
loophole through the ruler 12
first there's long-term exposure to the
intemperate schism
and the time or text will call that
exposure theory it's basically working
River Song hurry generations
shoes expose while she was a fetus
inside have any poon high fives for sex
on it artist
another theory is the present
self-replicating biogenic molecules that
kinda rearrange in repair tissue
will call that the Nanavati re another
theory is that restaurant altered Tyler
genetics to give them triple helix DNA
in that third helix is what enables our
generation
call a genetic theory number two
manipulation are trying energy
so think that this is being like the
many Koreans in Star Wars
only in name only it's like this strange
force that's connected to the essence of
life itself
as well as time travel it's a background
radiation
during the doctor's wife its actually
warehouse was feeding on when it ready
to take over the Tartus
so it's possible that the doctor could
find a way to manipulate are trying to
energy using the Tartus
to gonna fill up his life force gas tank
so to speak in my number one theory we
can also think reverse after this one
too
this is the escalation theory so during
the forced to the dead she said the
doctor
has begun to gain powers beyond that
have a normal time lower
that could also mean he's getting
regeneration powers beyond that have a
normal time Lord
the interesting thing about this theory
is that he really wasn't aware of how he
was changing on a fundamental level
until River Song told them that so it's
possible that he totally still believes
in israel it well
I think that after 12 he's definitely
going to die so come Christmas
he can actually think that something
really really terrible is going to
happen just be totally surprised when
every because Peter Capaldi
so lots of theories some with more
evidence than others be sure to post
your best
regeneration theory in the comments
below remember we're trying to figure
out how the doctor is going to survive
past well
because the BBC is it gonna stop making
doctor who after next year
or after Peter a party decides to leave
like I said earlier I'm doing my
doctor who asked emergency Q&A video
next week we should I leave your
comments eliasson
already asked for a longer video than
the 1i posted last time so I'll try to
pick at least have your questions to
answer
in the meantime check out my Doctor Who
Christmas tree the video by clicking
here
and check out my latest game it runs
video by clicking here thank you so much
watching of the guys tonight
have 5 p.m.